j'avais proposé comment dire cela au
premier tour alors à partir du moment où
il y avait quatre places pour 7,90 pour
145 c'est normal qu'il y en a une deux
mois sinon comment ceux qui qui
acceptent de ce regrouper au premier
tour pour elle le comprendre ça serait
une injustice pour eux donc je pense que
tout le monde l'a bien compris il
comprit y compris les vers et les
personnes qui les représentaient donc
c'est pas un changement de programme ce
serait complètement ridicule il y a 47%
des tourangers qui ont accepté le
programme le changer ça me paraîtrait de
la politique politicienne bon simplement
on va comment dire renforcer un certain
nombre de secteurs qui qui correspondent
au développement durable